Speaker 1: We have some very interesting political
election news in the Texas 6th Congressional
District Republican primary.
This is two Republicans running against each
other.
The Trump endorsed candidate lost.
And it wasn't a huge blowout, but it was a
loss.
And this is our first signal, about twenty,
twenty two, which is going to serve to inform
what happens in twenty twenty four from the
standpoint of the Republican presidential
candidate and whether that will be Donald
Trump.
Remember that we are working backwards now
in twenty twenty four.
Republicans will need some candidate to run
for president.
The question is, is that going to be Donald
Trump?
Well, Trump running in twenty four will be
informed by how do the Trump backed candidates
do in November of twenty twenty two?
How do Republicans do in November of twenty
twenty two in the House and the Senate?
Well, to get to that, you have to start looking
at some of the primaries that are taking place
right now.
And in the Texas 6th Congressional District
so far, Donald Trump has one loss in that
Texas congressional district.
Jake Elzy, the non Trump Republican, has defeated
the Trump backed rival Susan.
Right.
So chalk this up as a loss for Donald Trump.
Let's take a look.
Republican Jake Elzy of Texas won a House
seat on Tuesday night over a rival backed
by Donald Trump dealing the former president
a defeat in a test of his endorsement power
since leaving office.
ELSS come from behind victory over Republican
Susan Wright, the widow of the late Rep..
Ron Wright is a special congressional election.
Runoff near Dallas is likely to be celebrated
by Trump antagonists who have warned against
his continued hold on the Republican Party.
Elzy was carrying more than 53 percent of
the vote, and Texas is sixth congressional
district, with results from almost all precincts
reported.
One of the things we've seen from this campaign
is a positive outlook.
A Reagan Republican outlook for the future
of our country is what the people of the 6th
District really, really want, Elzy said to
supporters.
The runoff election came down to the two Republicans
in a race to succeed Congressman Ron Wright,
who in February became the first member of
Congress to die after being diagnosed with
covid-19.
Susan Wright, a Republican Party activist
and widow of the late congressman, carried
the endorsement of Trump into the special
election runoff.
A few differences in policy separated the
candidates, giving the race in north Texas
the feel of a Republican primary.
Far from running on an anti Trump platform,
Elzy did not try distancing himself from the
twice impeached former president.
He instead sought to overcome the lack of
Trump's backing by raising more money and
showing off endorsements, including that of
Rick Perry.
So this is actually a really big deal in a
sense.
Twenty, twenty four is now.
And what I mean by that is we are getting
into although we still have a little while,
this was a special runoff.
We still have some months until they really
get going.
But we're starting to get into primaries for
twenty, twenty two, which are going to determine
what happens in November of twenty twenty
two, which will determine what happens in
twenty twenty four.
And Donald Trump already backing some primary
candidates and the first one here has lost
this was the Trump candidate and they did
not win.
So this is you know, it's a sample size of
one.
We still don't know what it portends for the
bigger idea of Donald Trump being a kingmaker
in twenty, twenty two.
But this is already an interesting sign.
And when I was interviewed by Trump's former
lawyer, Michael Cohen, a couple of weeks ago,
Cohen said he doesn't think Trump is ultimately
going to run.
And the reason Trump won't run is it's going
to be clear to Trump that he's not going to
win if he runs in twenty twenty four.
That's Michael Cohen's perspective.
He may well be right.
He's been right about many things and he's
been, you know, not right about some things.
If indeed Trump is going to be convinced that
he's not going to win, part of it will be
that the people he chooses, the people he
backs for 20, 20 to lose.
And that is at least what we saw in the Texas
6th Congressional District.
We'll have more coverage of that race and
others that are upcoming on The David Pakman
Show Instagram, which you can find at David
Pakman show.